we're going to get into our first
question from libby hill from indy wire
libby
it's all you go for it
hold up hi libby
hi guys congratulations thank you it's a
big night yeah long i have a question
i have a question for you about season
three
uh
are you looking at ten episodes for that
upcoming season or or are you not
getting ahead of yourself at this point
they uh they being apple asked for 12
episodes um
and this time ahead of time and this
time ahead of time so yeah so we'll
we'll be doing 12 episodes yeah as of
now
great yeah great yeah but are you
offering us more episodes yeah
well i mean
i i feel it feels
wrong to say it publicly but i'll uh dm
you all right perfect perfect i'll let
you know
i'll be in touch
congratulations thanks thank you very
much libby next up we've got liz from
ctv utah is there a way to maybe give
these guys a little more volume too so
we can hear him a little better
i don't
please
hey it's liz hey can you hear me here we
go hannah
and i get in the middle come here
come on in hannah
hi there welcome welcome hey
congratulations it's liz tornier with
etalk canada
to the cast and crew uh congratulations
and jason thank you so much for keeping
us laughing and bringing us joy into one
of the hardest times in our lifetime and
throughout this pandemic now there is no
question that ted lasso is a true fan
favorite so what would ted say right now
in this moment
oh i mean that's
it's pretty expensive to get me to do
that i don't know
i i i could do it for you as jason uh
you know i think i think he would be uh
you know happy that we were in the mix
as much as we were and that so many
departments were
um you know spot lit or spotlighted
however you want to say it and um and
and the fact that um
you know we we walked away with a few of
the trophies i think he'd be excited
about but i think he'd be more thrilled
about the rewards of getting to do good
work with people that you like than the
awards for getting having done it
absolutely bringing joy to everyone
thank you guys so much for the show